welcome to this video bit of a late
start sometimes I start the game and
forget to start the recording okay we
got a Scott joking playing my bishop
before that line let's see what the
opponent is coming up with maybe I can
premiums that in case he really is
taking and nope okay well here I can
actually win a pond if I want to eat but
do I want this I don't think so take on
default icon before I looks weird but
I'm better retreat before I think of
questionable value what exactly is this
move doing I will go to be six anyway so
um okay yeah my favorite move in this
position would beam queen age for but
not sure I can oh wait i can actually if
i go queen f6 this Bishop is free and
that all this looks a bit loose in my
book one day I one down the night s6
where I have an idea playing with d5
here Bishop g5 Knight f6 this looks
quite quite comfortable
you cannot retreat now and I'm
threatening c6 as well yeah the problem
at the end is the default at the rook on
a one look at the rook on a wall this is
a big problem Bishop goes away I go and
take windey form threatening have to
made threatening on a one and if he
takes Bishop divorce trapping the rook
and be very very tricky already I don't
even see him for white to be honest
yeah what is by doing I mean this should
be three Queenie for it looks like looks
like there is something going down after
that check yep something like that was
probably necessary but okay I've got a
v6 here
yeah I can I can I just take it that
that's the easiest solution there is
also a stuff on f2 going on so after ye
five okay can just take here now and
still queen d 4 will win material
possibly Queen d4 here this Knight c3
okay okay so keep it simple just to take
this just two peas up now go night 859
h5 this queen e five okay we'd like to
trade queens of course the term does not
seem possible on the favorite
circumstances so I just continue this
should be for now let's look III okay
isn't there some way to I can't I can't
I can play that actually some way to use
this this awkward Queen position Bishop
c7 is good would have been good the move
before even Bishop c7 this night h5
winning even more material Queen edge
for this g5 winning yeah well I don't
know the house really winning the Queen
really Bishop takes hd25 bishop h2 I was
even a maid coming no he must play a for
now I guess they only only move that
it's not instantly giving away even more
material and then
Germany we move and just return you
five to shoot c4 yeah it's very
difficult to to to not do it now but we
all know you sometimes manage to to do
the this is the craziest things Reggie
for you there are easier ways probably
to do it but this should be quite
convincing io e three years now now
falling um yeah check
oh okay it's no real meat or anything
okay let's go look everyone this is a
bit more exciting I mean yeah relatively
um bit more exciting than I wished for I
should have to maybe just this there is
this check here night have to check
things you one now there is no direct
win strangely enough at least I do not
see it check 23 maybe they are queen bee
three that's pretty good rook takes the
drop key one that's very easy like windy
one meeting here maybe this one
threatening the rook with night HD
double check and rook takes Queen d1 is
still made yeah that's pretty good yeah
that that's enough I guess
double check check
yeah this was surprisingly am yeah what
was in trouble surprisingly quickly
checkmate yeah before this slightly
strange move really I mean I didn't
really trust this one bit since looks
strange yeah it just it's just very good
compensation so I useless to play that
like here and at everything very good
compensation so okay but I want to go
here we have any way yeah and this is in
fact what the computer also wants to
play d 5 with an edge one point is that
after this the computer wants to play
Queenie 70 just even stronger than what
I thought I've thought just Knight f6
with a good position but in fact this
isn't so great after Queenie too okay
maybe 97 biquini 7 is the strongest but
I'm not sure if I would have played that
yeah it here I would see 6 is even
stronger yeah of course why did not play
c6 actually hmm yeah now the engine
points out that this isn't entirely
clear because the capture now loses the
Queen so Knight f6 for instance and
castles yeah it is good for black but
it's not a winning okay so I went here
which is also ok but now he has Bishop
e3 avoiding material losses but ok the
position of course is excellent for
black to bishops better structure light
square weaknesses that's not good here
yeah but this is flat-out losing him
yeah bishop at seven diseases and it's
nothing really but he already was Sir
was pretty much pretty much lost alright
thanks for watching